and tell me how long have you and shelby
been married for
we were married for over 14 years 14
years you guys lived here in east las
vegas and
been going through the pandemic um
sunday absolute tragedy what has what if
the last 48 hours been like for you
um it's been pretty much a complete
shock
complete disbelief something i could not
even
imagine or dream up if i even
took the hardest effort i possibly could
because what happened was a flat out
horrendous and unnecessary
tragedy that was 100 percent avoidable
i'm sure that day talk to me about it
was she going out for her typical bike
ride well what did she typically like to
do
was that normal for her to go on a bike
ride it was especially on her days off
which she always had sunday off and she
would go out and want to ride from here
out to the wetlands park loop and go out
there and ride the bike trail
that was out there and sometimes we
would even go out and ride
all the way out to lake las vegas we
made that ride to and from there
a number of times and i just didn't
happen to go with her
this prior ride she was already
predetermined that she was going to go
and so she decided to go and take off
for her
typical ride on the wetlands park loop
and hollywood boulevard
normal route normal route yeah
and you realize something was wrong
though
right about 10 in the morning when she
didn't come back yeah about 10 in the
morning which would have put her about
three hours into the ride
and typically ends up she'll get back
within two hours
but i know that there's a few people
that are on that path that she used to
work with
um at a prior hotel that she would stop
and chat with so i'm figuring that maybe
the conversation
drew out a little long you know they
reached the park out there and sitting
on the benches
things of that nature and just kept
giving it the
you know benefit of the doubt as far as
time goes and then started all of a
sudden
calling and text messaging um in which
every single one of those efforts went
unanswered
which i'm sure for you is worrisome yes
very worrisome
because that would be uh unlike her you
left the house
you went to hollywood boulevard yes when
you first noticed the scene
yes because i was on my way i loaded my
bike up
um in one of my vehicles and i was
headed out to wetlands park
i mean i changed clothes got into my
cycling gear
with the full intent on going out to the
wetlands park loop
and i was going to go out there and ride
that loop go looking for her and um
and as i'm leaving my house what roughly
about what one and a half miles from
here
i come across uh some caution tape on
hollywood
and i'm thinking right off the bat
that's when kind of like the first
slight gut punch hit me thinking okay
you know with all the connecting of the
dots of unanswered phone calls
unanswered messages
things of that nature and then here we
go i've got caution tape
on a portion of the route that i know
for a fact that she would have taken
and uh but at the same time i didn't
want to jump the gun
because i'm thinking well you know
they've got a pretty large sizable
area blocked off here and that
usually generates you know from large
car accidents
and plus i'm also thinking to myself too
that at this particular
area is blocked off and here she is
she's been gone for four hours
and most accidents are usually cleaned
up in a
relatively short period of time you know
not five or ten minutes but they would
have been cleaned up
relatively short and i'm thinking man
okay she's been gone for four hours
which means that she's already two hours
late
so the chances of that being her would
be extremely slim
because that means this would have
already had to be going on for well over
two hours
so that's why i didn't really i didn't
panic too much at that point
but then connecting the dots when did
you finally realize that this
was shelling involved well i went around
i started getting some information
from some of the officers over there and
they were
holding back on some of the information
i could feel that
which understandably so and
more i kept asking and kept trying to
give them a description and said hey i
need to know if
my wife is in there or do i need to
continue on into the desert to try to
find her
i said i just need a simple yes no it's
all i'm looking for
and then as i'm looking back in there
i'm looking probably 150 yards
to the north because i'm right now i'm
at the south end
of the blockage of hollywood so i'm look
i'm facing north at this point
and i see about 150 yards in i see an
object covered with a white sheet
and you know that could be you know
whomever whatever
or whatever you know but and it was also
on the west side of hollywood
okay so that would mean that the only
way she would have been on the west side
of hollywood
is if she was still going out she was
still going
to the trail okay because that means she
would have been going with traffic
and then when the officers kept trying
to
holding back information but then when i
ended up asking them
how long ago did all this take place and
they said oh 7 30 in the morning
well right then and there that's when i
even let them know i said well i can
guarantee you right now that's her
i said because 20 minutes from my house
puts me exactly
where that sheet is at so that's when i
knew
right there without them even telling me
giving me any more information
which they you know which which that
took a while to get so that's when i
knew
was at that point i know it's only been
48 hours but
how has life just changed because this
was so
sudden yeah it's changed in a way that
uh
that you wouldn't that you wouldn't
believe you know
house isn't as full um things are a
little bit
chaos chaotic a little bit to where you
know things that normally are getting
done at certain
points of time during the day um they
get you know they're getting done
differently or they're not getting done
because maybe it's something that
maybe shelley would have done like maybe
feeding the cats at a certain time
things of that nature and it's
you know and you can tell they're acting
a little bit different right now
you know and then not to not to mention
the the overwhelmingly abundance of
uh phone calls that i'm getting from
family members and friends
who are every single one of them have
been nothing short of astounding
um you know we're all trying to support
one another
and then more you know more importantly
are sitting there trying to support me
and i'm trying to let them know i'm
supporting them because it's the loss of
their sibling and
you know their their family member as
well so uh yeah it's been
it's been quite a 48 hours
what was shelley what was she like what
do you want people to know about her
she was probably the nicest person
you'll ever meet
she was a ray of sunshine when she walks
into a room you can just
see and feel and hear the glow coming
right off of her
if you didn't know her you would know
her in a matter of minutes
in a very good way and you would not
forget her
and that's and that's about it i mean
she's always thinking about others
always
i mean there's always stories about
right here people all the time yeah
shelley's always she went to the cupcake
store and
and before you know it here she is she's
knocking on my door and here she is
she's bringing me a box of cupcakes of
one of every flavor
to make sure i had some and and my mom
is always saying
shelley's always bringing me making sure
i had cookies whenever she went to her
favorite cookie place and
and my mom's not even asking her enough
and she just shows up with them and
that's just who she was i mean that she
is always
looking out for somebody else always
would you consider her
your soul mate your world yes
how would you describe your relationship
oh it was very
solid very rock solid a lot of common
interests
a lot of common ground and common ideas
and common thinking
um and um you know
both of us you know we had we shared the
nature of no bad habits so that was easy
it's not like she had to deal with my
bad habits or me dealing with her bad
habits that
could you know usually pay a toll on a
marriage or something
and um so yeah we like the same things
we like to travel to the same places
and um everything we like to do this we
just like to
adventure into these different places
and it was great
yeah yes yep
two of them inside and one of them
outside that was a
feral cat that we ended up saving after
she ended up getting trapped here and we
had to
turn her and her babies in and the
babies got adopted
and gracie did not get adopted
and there was only two options and we
did not like their option
option one which would have been for her
to no longer be
around and so they said they would have
to return her to us
and so we took her and i was finally
able to uh
somewhat break her to where now she
comes right
up to us she comes we came right up to
me and shelly
every day some of my family members she
recognizes but just
is not as quick to come up to them
so yeah so she's part of the family what
will you miss the most about shelley
um just the life that she brings the
life that she just brings into this
world
that's uh that's what i'll just remember
because she just brought
life and goodness into everything
and um yeah that's one of the big things
there because
my best friend basically he's he's like
eight or nine years older than me so
obviously he's lived a longer life than
i have and
i've known him for 35 years he basically
ended up telling me said lonnie let me
tell you something
and his name is jerry and jerry knows
exactly who
who you are out there who i'm speaking
of and he said long out of all the
people that i know
and all the people that i've ever known
this
event that took place shelly is the
absolute
last person that this should have
happened to
period that was the end of story right
there and that sums it up right there
some may be watching this and thinking
wow you're
staying so strong how are you doing that
no i have my moments yeah trust me
i have my moments it's uh
you know even though i am a
strong-minded individual
i definitely have many many moments i
definitely have a great blessing of
having very good
uh supportive support system which is
made up of
family and great friends two of which
you're going to meet here momentarily
and they have they've been nothing short
of phenomenal
so supporting you through this yes yes
does it even feel real no it doesn't
what does it feel like to you it feels
like maybe she's back east visiting her
family back in ohio
maybe she's on vacation back there
visiting her sister cheryl
having a good time with her cousins back
there and
and she'll just be home any day but the
reality is
yeah reality is she's never coming home
when you say that do you even believe
those words i'd not yet i don't
does it just hurt your heart it does
you can see it in your eyes yeah it does
is there anything else that you would
want to share about shelley
and just her legacy the impact she's had
here
in the valley and for you um well
shelley was uh phenomenal she was just
uh
just a streak of um
amazement what she was just a big ray of
sunshine
brought good upon everything and to
everybody that she came in contact with
[Music]
probably every single one of her
co-workers currently and past would say
the same thing
and my wife shelley she had she had no
enemies
i can tell you that right now she had no
enemies
and that is uh very tough to say about
anybody
you mentioned her co-workers you
mentioned she was the hotel director for
the cannery
yes hotel casino on craig road yes uh
owned by
boyd gaming yes they did send us a
statement
they said we are deeply saddened by the
tragic and senseless loss of our team
member
shelley she was well known and well
liked by the entire cannery team
and we will miss her our thoughts and
prayers are with her family and friends
during this very difficult time
hearing that statement what does that
mean to you
well to be honest with you um
i already knew that because i already
knew how they because i've been in
contact
with that particular company and i've
known many employees
at that company for quite a long time
and so i already know how they feel
about her
so that right there definitely does not
surprise me one bit
yeah i mean i'm saying okay that's par
for the course it's what it is it's
basically par for the course right there
any plans right now about memorial or
how you
may want to remember her well that
that's currently being worked on right
now
i have i have family and friends
assisting me with that right now and
getting all that arranged certain people
doing
certain duties on that right now so um i
could not give you a definitive right
at this moment yep thank you
appreciate it you got it